oh hi whoo it's another long hot brain
baking summer here in the wired office
in uh where are we San Francisco ah
that's better it's another frigid boggy
a summer here in San Francisco you know
what the summer means that's right a
lack of video games on store shelves
fortunately about five years ago
Microsoft pioneered a new plan called
summer of arcade in which they released
a lot of major downloadable games to
help fill out those summer doldrums this
idea was so good that both Nintendo and
Sony have copied it so here's a rundown
of the major downloadable games coming
to you this summer on the Xbox
Playstation 3 and in head of three dias
we'll kick things off with Xbox 360s
summer of arcade available now tony
hawk's pro skater HD ditches the big
rideable fake skateboard and gets back
to what made the series break hi def
remixes of the best levels from the
classic originals racketeer is a Kinect
game in which you use your body to
launch and guide cannonballs into a
castle sort of a first-person Angry
Birds deadlight is a 2d side-scrolling
survival game with a shadowy
post-apocalyptic graphic design and lots
of zombies hybrid is a first-person
shooter that breaks all the rules of the
genre it's created by fit sell the
makers of the innovative scribblenauts
finally dust an elysian tail is a
gorgeous hand animated 2d side-scrolling
action game now if you buy any 3 of the
summer of arcade games Microsoft will
give you a bonus 400 points to spend on
whatever you want not to be outdone Sony
is also offering its own summer
promotion and it calls it PSN flesh the
expendables 2 is a four-player
cooperative shooter based on the
star-studded action film franchise sound
shapes is the playstation vita game
we've all been waiting for a musical
journey of surprise and delight and a
playstation 3 version comes along
with it for free papo yo-yo is an
intriguing indie game about the
relationship between a boy and his
father we are really excited about this
one here at game life and finally
counterstrike global Offensive updates
the classic competitive shooter series
with playstation move motion controller
support if that's your thing sony says
it will also add funds to your
PlayStation wallet for every PSN play
game you buy if you buy two games you
get three dollars by three games you get
six dollars if you buy all four games
you've got an extra ten dollars to spend
on more PlayStation downloads now
Nintendo has also said this year that it
wants in on some of that hot summer
promotion lovin and it is bringing us
8-bit summer for the Nintendo 3ds
releasing classic games to your new
portable system Nintendo kick things off
with a true classic the original Legend
of Zelda for the NES next Kirby's
pinball land drops everybody's favorite
pink eating machine into a wacky pinball
inspired world kid icarus of myths and
monsters is the second adventure of the
nearly flightless angel child and wario
land super mario land 3 is a unique spin
off of the Mario series putting you for
the first time in the role of the greedy
bad guy and if you're a Sega fan sonic
blast and sonic labyrinth are two games
you probably didn't get to enjoy unless
you own a game gear back in the day and
also had an endless supply of double-a
batteries and of course if you buy more
than one of Nintendo's 8-bit summer
games you get nothing absolutely nothing
nothing with a satisfaction of helping
Nintendo return back to profitability
and isn't that enough happy summer
everybody
you